So you can press play.
Okay.
Spacebar.
For the first few moves here,
I did remember everything perfectly fine, so this was pretty
normal to me. Felt okay. That down block
was fine, and the middle blocks were something that I had practiced
a bit, so I was okay with it. When it came to the high block kick part, I was a little
unsure, but I think I did it right, so that part was
alright. My front kick form could definitely be better. The down block at the end
and the last low punch
were quite good, I think.
So, as you can see, your pattern is
scored based on the number 10, so out of 10
is your mark. As you can see, it's split up into
two parts. We have our accuracy and our presentation on this side.
So, we'll start off with the accuracy first. So, your accuracy
is actually scored from a 4. So, from the number
4, you're actually marked during your
presentation of your pattern, and then with that one, any mistakes
that you make, whether it's a
minor mistake you get minus of 0.1 if it's a major mistake you get minus 0.3 so i'll just let you guys